[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen alles
Wichtige vom Sport gibt es von Norbert
König in einer Viertelstunde guten Abend
und wir schauen auf unsere großen Themen
Drohnenangriffe auf Russland Präsident
Putin ordnet stärkere Grenzüberwachung
an
mehr Tempo bei der Energiewende die
Regierung will das schon ab nächstem
Jahr neue Heizungsanlagen überwiegend
mit erneuerbaren Energien betrieben
werden
und so trocken wie noch nie Frankreich
kämpft mit einer winterdöre
[Musik]
die ukrainischen Truppen geraten in
bachmut immer stärker unter Druck von
ukrainischer Seite heißt es russische
Wagner Söldner versuchten die Stadt
einzukesseln um sie wird seit Monaten
heftig gekämpft auf Russland gab es
jetzt mehrere Drohnenangriffe die
russische Führung macht die Ukraine
dafür verantwortlich Christian Volk
berichtet
am Himmel über der russischen Stadt
Belgorod fliegt eine kampfdrohne aus der
Ukraine meldet der Kreml Kia Farbe in
mehreren Regionen versucht die zivile
Infrastruktur anzugreifen auch hier in
colomna rund 110 km südöstlich von
Moskau nicht die ersten Vorfälle dieser
Art dennoch zeigt sich Präsident Putin
alarmiert fordert seinen Geheimdienst zu
härteren Grenzkontrollen auf
jetzt setzen wir dort Grenzsoldaten
Geheimdienst Flugzeuge russische
Streitkräfte und die Nationalgarde ein
ihre Aufgabe ist es Sabotage Truppen
eine Mauer in den Weg zu stellen und
alle Versuche zu unterbinden Waffen und
Munition
illegal nach Russland zu bringen
währenddessen in der Ostukraine dort
setzen beide Seiten Massen an Waffen und
Munition ein der Druck auf die Stadt
bachmut steigt nach ukrainischen Angaben
sind die eigenen Soldaten fast
eingekesselt nur noch eine Straße bleibt
für einen möglichen Rückzug
wir greifen sie an mit allem was wir
haben auch die Russen verschonen
niemanden das ganze Gebiet ist mit
Leichen gefüllt
schwerer Beschluss und kaum noch
Geländegewinne auf beiden Seiten auch
weiter südlich in der Region Donezk hier
haben sich die Ukraine eingegraben doch
der Frühling bedeutet Schlamm und der
macht es schwer voran zu kommen dennoch
in etwa einem Monat zur Militärexperten
könnte die Ukraine eine Gegenoffensive
im Süden starten
dann könnten sie die russische Front und
in zwei Teile spalten und außerdem ihre
Artillerie mitteldeutlicht näher zur
Krim bringen damit wären sie in der Lage
die logistischen Zugänge zur Krim von
Westen aus abzuschneiden beziehungsweise
mit Heimat also mit 80 km Reichweite
außer Kraft zu setzen und damit den
Krieg dann in die Krim hineintragen und
zwar ohne dass sie konventionell
einführen müssten zur militärischen Lage
von Präsident Putin heute keine weiteren
Details sein Fokus lag stattdessen bei
der Sicherheitslage im eigenen Land
in Russland ist für uns für Bega in der
Ukraine Hannah Hebestreit schauen wir
mal als erstes nach Moskau für zu ihnen
immer mal wieder berichtet ja die
russische Führung offen über die ja
schwierige Sicherheitslage normalerweise
wird ja aber darauf Wert gelegt immer so
Stärke zu demonstrieren warum diese
Offenheit wie jetzt bei den
Drohnenangriffen
ja das wirkt erstmal überraschend
verletzlich wenn ein rund ein Land wie
Russland sein Territorium und seine
Infrastruktur nicht gegen Drohnen
schützen kann aber erstens wird in
diesen Berichten immer Wert darauf
gelegt zu sagen und zu betonen dass die
Angreifer ihr Ziel nicht oder nicht
vollumfänglich erreicht haben und
zweitens hilft diese Bedrohung Präsident
Putin sogar denn der Wladimir Putin der
behauptet ja immer wieder das Russland
in Gefahr sei das sogar der Fortbestand
des Landes in Gefahr sei und der
rechtfertigt damit das Töten in der
Ukraine das harte Vorgehen gegen
Oppositionelle hier im Land und auch die
vielen Opfer die er seine eigenen
Bevölkerung abverlangt der Präsident
hält Russland in einer dauerhaften
latentenalarm Zustand und das liefert
ihm immer neue Argumente dafür den
Wirkungsbereich seiner
Sicherheitsbehörden und seiner
Geheimdienste auszubauen und sein
autoritären Staat zu zementieren
blicken wir da jetzt mal auf die
Kriegslage der Ukraine Henna in bachmut
sind die Ukraine wir haben es eben auch
gesehen stark unter Druck was bedeutet
das denn für die militärische Gesamtlage
naja das ist ein ziemliches Blutbad was
ich dort abspielt wir haben heute mit
der Zustand die militärkommandatur hier
in niepo gesprochen die für den gesamten
Ostbereich der Ukraine zuständig ist und
da sagt man uns dass die Russen
tatsächlich starke eliteverbände und
Panzereinheiten nördlich von bachmut
zusammengezogen haben und bis zu 300
Artillerie Geschosse pro Tag auf die
Stellung in der Ukraine abfeuern und von
einer einzigen höheren wir auch warum
bleiben die Ukrainer in ihren Stellungen
noch stehen das mag damit zu tun haben
dass man Reserveeinheiten die bislang
noch im Ausland geschult werden Zeit
geben möchte dafür dass sie die Schulung
abschließen können und dann hat er aber
auch angedeutet dass sie im letzten
Sommer ein ähnliches Szenario gab da
hätten sich ukrainische Truppen dann
zurückgezogen von sehr verrückter Nest
war damals die Rede und wenige Tage oder
um wenige Zeit später dann rund um Raki
die russischen Verbände zurückzuschlagen
das könnte so eine Art Blaupause sein
für das was ich hier in den nächsten
Tagen Wochen oder Monaten weiter im
Süden abspielen könnte vielen Dank für
die Einschätzung
ist Außenministerin bärburg hat sich
besorgt über die geplante Justizreform
in Israel geäußert unter anderem will
die Regierung die Befugnisse des
Obersten Gerichtshofs einschränken
außerdem sei es ein großer Fehler die
Todesstrafe wieder einführen zu wollen
sagte bärburg bei einer gemeinsamen
Pressekonferenz mit ihrem israelischen
Amtskollegen er forderte die
Bundesregierung auf den Druck auf Iran
im Konflikt um das Atomprogramm zu
erhöhen
um den Klimaschutz im Gebäudebereich zu
verbessern könnte der Einbau neuer Gas
und Ölheizung schon ab kommenden Jahr
verboten werden das Sehen Pläne der
Bundesregierung vor laut
Koalitionsvertrag sollte das Verbot erst
ab 2025 kommen das ganze vorzuziehen
sieht die Opposition kritisch mehr von
Patrizia wiedermeier
schon jetzt kann sich der Mainzer
Heizungsbauer Markus Herbert vor
Aufträgen kaum retten noch mehr Tempo
beim Einbau von neuen Heizungen so wie
sich das die Ampel vorstellt das
scheitert seiner Meinung nach am
Fachkräftemangel an Lieferengpässen und
auch am erhöhten Zeitaufwand warum so
ungefähr für eine Wärmepumpe die
dreifache Zeit zwei bis dreifache Zeit
wie bei einem Gas ölgerät
ähm da fehlt einfach die Manpower nicht
jedes Gebäude eignet sich auch für eine
Wärme teilweise sind dann da auch
erstmal bauliche Maßnahmen zu tätigen
spannend es dürfte daher schwierig
werden die Pläne des Wirtschafts- und
Bauministeriums umzusetzen erste Details
eines gemeinsamen Entwurfs sehen das Aus
für alle Gas und Ölheizung vor so steht
es auch im Koalitionsvertrag klar ist
wer das Ziel des Ausbaus der
erneuerbaren und auch der
Energieeffizienz und Energieeinsparung
ernst nimmt kommt am Thema Gebäude nicht
vorbei geplant ist dass ab 2024 jede neu
eingebaute Heizung auf Basis von 65%
erneuerbaren Energien betrieben werden
muss ein vollständiges Verbot kommt
deutlich später der vorliegende Entwurf
sieht vor dass spätestens bis zum Jahre
2045 die Nutzung von fossilen
Energieträgern beendet und danach alle
Heizungen vollständig mit erneuerbaren
Energien betrieben werden müssen die FDP
beschwichtigt wir haben uns auf die
Klimaschutzziele verständigt gar keine
Frage gleichzeitig kann das natürlich
nicht mit der Brechstange funktionieren
man kann niemanden zwingen
eine funktionierende Heizung auszubauen
und eine andere einzubauen heftige
Kritik dagegen von der Opposition die
Ampel ist dringend aufgefordert diese
falsche Entscheidung nicht umzusetzen
und anstatt Verbote Anreize zu setzen
das heißt Klima Bonus für den Austausch
von Ölheizungen noch gibt es viele
offene Frage noch liegt der finale
Gesetzentwurf auch nicht vor
die Regierung plant also ein Verbot von
neuen Öl- und Gasheizung ab 2024 was
heißt das für bestehende Anlagen und
worauf müssen sich die Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher einstellen was wenn die
Heizung kaputt geht Antworten dazu und
unserer ZDF heute App
und aus Berlin kommt noch dies gut zwei
Wochen nach der Wahl will
SPD-Spitzenkandidatin Franziska Giffey
ihrer Partei laut Medienberichten
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit der
cdu-vorschlagen damit wäre die SPD nur
noch Juniorpartner CDU Spitzenkandidat
Kai Wegner könnte neue Regierender
Bürgermeister werden die rechnerisch
möglich wäre aber auch eine
schwarz-grüne Koalition oder eine
Fortsetzung von Rot-Grün rot
die Gewerkschaft verdi will am Freitag
den öffentlichen Nahverkehr in sechs
Bundesländern massiv bestreiten damit
soll der Druck in den laufenden
Tarifverhandlungen für den öffentlichen
Dienst der Kommunen und des Bundes
erhöht werden in Niedersachsen und
anderen Bundesländern legten
Beschäftigte heute erneut ihre Arbeit
zeitweise nieder betroffen waren unter
anderem der Nahverkehr Kitas und die
Müllabfuhr Verdi und der Beamtenbund
fordern ein Plus von 10,5% mindestens
aber 500 Euro mehr im Monat
und Warnstreiks werden auch bei der
Deutschen Bahn wahrscheinlicher denn der
erste Runde der Tarifverhandlung wurde
heute schon nach zwei Stunden
unterbrochen und zwar ohne Ergebnis und
das liegt Hans-jürgen Pier
lautstarke Untermalung ihrer Forderungen
die Bahngewerkschaft EVG verlangt
Gehaltserhöhungen von mindestens 12% bei
der Deutschen Bahn doch schon nach gut
zwei Stunden brach sie die Verhandlungen
heute morgen wieder ab der Arbeitgeber
war in keinem unserer forderungspunkte
in der Lagern verhandlungsfähiges
Angebot auf dem Tisch zu liegen
geschweige denn überhaupt ein Angebot
auf dem Tisch zu legen und damit gab es
nicht zu verhandeln Abbruch noch bevor
es richtig losging 12% mehr Gehalt
fordert die Gewerkschaft mindestens aber
650 €. was für untere Gehaltsgruppen
einer Erhöhung um mehr als 12% bedeuten
würde das ganze bei einer
Vertragslaufzeit von einem Jahr es ist
die höchste Lohnforderung die die EVG je
erhoben hat begründet mit aktuellen
Inflationsraten nach Angaben der DB hat
sie daneben aber auch fast 60 weitere
Forderungen gestellt worüber der
Bahnvorstand vor einem eigenen
Lohnangebot erst sprechen wollte EVG hat
verlangt dass wir ohne inhaltliche
Erörterung ein Angebot vorlegen und das
ist aus unserer Sicht derzeit nicht
möglich weil zunächst eben die
inhaltliche Erörterung der vielen
Forderungen erforderlich ist doch die
Gewerkschaft bleibt dabei ohne Angebot
keine Gespräche wenn wir überhaupt gar
keine Angebote bekommen dann wäre die
Verhandlung weiterhin unterbrochen und
würde dann in die Eskalation hinauf
saufen Streik in den nächsten Wochen
will die IVG ihre Forderungen jetzt auch
50 bahnkonkurrenten vorlegen erst danach
ist mit Streiks zu rechnen
drei Wochen ist das her das bei zwei
großen Erdbeben in der Türkei und Syrien
mehr als 50.000 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen sind
die Situation für die Überlebenden ist
prekär mehr als eine Million Menschen
sind Schätzungen zufolge seit den Beben
obdachlos Peter Theisen beginnt seine
Reportage in Malatya und berichtet
darüber wie schwierig das helfen vor Ort
ist
ist immer noch fassungslos am Tag nach
dem verheerenden Erdbeben kam er mit
einem schnell zusammengestellten
Hilfskonvoi nach Malatya 500 km hat er
zurückgelegt und dann das wir haben eine
mobile Küche eingerichtet dann kamen
Polizei und der Katastrophenschutz
Abfahrt sie haben uns das Essen
weggenommen und das Geschirr und die
Kochgeräte beschlagnahmen die
Freiwilligen in Malatya oft Kurden und
Aleviten helfen nun an anderen Orten sie
sind meist Anhänger der
Oppositionspartei HDP und Glauben genau
deshalb werde Ihre Hilfe behindert der
staatliche Katastrophenschutz Abfahrt
wolle alles unter seiner Kontrolle
behalten sagen Kritiker und machen dafür
auch den Mann an der Spitze
verantwortlich Ismael palgolo ein
Gefolgsmann von Präsident Erdogan ein
Theologe ohne Erfahrung im
Katastrophenschutz
natürlich ist er dieser Katastrophe
nicht gewachsen aber Qualifikation zählt
ja nichts mehr nur Leute die man kennt
die absolut loyal sind kommen noch in
solche Positionen
[Musik]
auch der Darmstädter Arzt Jihan Celik
stieß auf Mauern als er helfen wollte in
einem zelldorf wo viel zu wenige
übermüdete Ärzte derzeit 48 Stunden am
Stück arbeiten ich habe gesagt ich bin
da ich kann helfen allerdings wurde das
dann quasi vom Gesundheitsministerium
abgelehnt man muss sich akkreditieren
lassen und momentan werden keine
weiteren akkreditationen ausgestellt
dabei war der bekannte Lungenarzt extra
aus Deutschland angereist nach einer
Odyssee durch das Katastrophengebiet
kann er nun in diesem Feld Lazarett
einer Oppositionspartei doch noch helfen
also momentan sind es vor allem die
Atemwegsinfektion es sind die bronchiten
vor allem der kleinen Kinder die
momentan unter freiem Himmel leben oder
im Zelt in der Kälte noch lange werden
hunderttausende Menschen Hilfe brauchen
deshalb bleibt auch Rezept weiter in
malatia 500 km von seiner Heimat
entfernt auch wenn die staatlichen
Behörden ihm und anderen Helfern immer
wieder Steine in den Weg legen
es sei wie ein Folterkellern gewesen mit
diesen Worten hat heute der Richter des
Landgerichts Köln die Taten eines
45-Jährigen aus Wellness Kirchen
beschrieben hatte Säugling und Kindern
schwere sexualisierte Gewalt angetan das
jüngste der Opfer war vier Wochen alt
der Täter wurde jetzt zu 14 einhalb
Jahren Haft verurteilt außerdem ordnete
das Gerichte Sicherungsverwahrung an ein
Bericht von Ariane Güte
menschenverachtend ungewöhnlich
sadistisch zum Fürchten mit diesen
Worten beschrieb der Richter in seiner
Urteilsbegründung die Taten des
45-Jährigen es seien außergewöhnlich
schwere Straftaten Markus R hatte
gestanden mindestens 14 Kindern im
säuglings- und Kleinkindalter in über
100 Fällen zum Teil schwere sexuelle
Gewalt angetan zu haben
14,5 Jahre Haft und Sicherungsverwahrung
urteilte das Kölner Landgericht der
Verurteilte sei eine Gefahr für die
Allgemeinheit die Kamera ist überzeugt
davon dass der
Angeklagte seine multiple sexuelle
präferenzstörung aufgrund des ungehemden
Auslebens in der Vergangenheit nicht in
den Griff bekommen wird seine Opfer
waren Mädchen und Jungen die Eltern zum
Babysitten anvertraut hatten Markus R
wohnte mit seiner Frau in wohlhabenden
Verhältnissen hier in Wermelskirchen bei
seiner Festnahme im Dezember 2021 saß
Markus R vor seinem geöffneten Computern
dem IT-Spezialisten Bl ieb keine Zeit
Spuren zu verwischen die Polizei fand
mehrere Millionen Bilder und Videos
außerdem enttarnte Sie weitere
pedokriminelle empathielos hat Markus er
den Prozess verfolgt das erschreckende
war jemanden zu erleben der uns von
grausamsten Straftaten berichtet uns
aber das Gefühl vermittelt er erklärt
uns wie er gerade ein Regal
zusammengebaut hat der Verurteilte wird
vermutlich nie wieder in Freiheit leben
der Winter in Deutschland war deutlich
zu warm sagen Meteorologen und zu
trocken
schlimmer noch hat es unseren Nachbarn
in Frankreich getroffen dort hat es am
32 Tagen in Folge im Januar Februar
nicht geregnet das ist die längste
Trockenperiode seit Beginn der
Wetteraufzeichnung 1959
bereits im vergangenen Sommer hatte das
Land und deiner langen Dürre gelitten
die Lager an manchen Orten nun
dramatisch Thomas Walde berichtet
Spaziergänger gehen auf dem Grund des
Lac de mobile im Süden Frankreichs wenig
erinnert daran dass dies ein See ist
oder einer war seit 30 Jahren lebt
Pierre terpo hier und hat so etwas noch
nicht gesehen
vor einem Jahr zur selben Zeit waren wir
bei 50 Millionen Kubikmetern und das
Wasser stand etwa dort wo das Grün
beginnt
trocken ist es auch auf dem Feld von
Jill in Zentral Frankreich zu trocken
sein persönlicher Eindruck wird durch
Wetterdaten bestätigt wenig Regen
bedeutet viele Probleme für den Bauern
das ist beunruhigend das verheißt nichts
Gutes für die weitere Saison wir haben
Angst wir hatten wasserspar Aufladen
manche Ort gibt es die schon das Dorf
Aurelia in den Pyrenäen hat kurzzeitig
das Trinkwasser abgestellt mangels
Niederschlags
das ist unsere Quelle es kommt nur noch
wenig an und in der vergangenen Woche
hatten wir gar nichts das gab's im
Winter noch nie die Messe der Landwirte
ist für französische Präsidenten ein
Pflichttermin in diesem Jahr stimmte
Emanuel macron die Landwirte aufs Sparen
ein
Nenner die Nation muss beim Wasser tun
was sie bei der Energie getan hat einen
genügsamkeitsplan erstellen wir müssen
als bürgerindustrie Kommunen und
Landwirte auf dieser Ressource achten
die rahwert
macron bereitet das Land auf
langfristige Veränderungen vor denn so
früh im Jahr gab es das noch nicht
Frankreich lernt ein neues Wort Winter
Dürre
bei den Nordischen Ski
Weltmeisterschaften im Planica gab es
heute keine Medaillen für deutsche
Wintersportlerinnen aber dafür wurde ja
ein kitzbüh gejubelt ja und zwar beim
para Ski Weltcup auf dem legendären ganz
langen bei bis zu 72% Gefälle im Slalom
Wald holt sich die halbseitig gelähmte
Anna Maria Rieder die aktuelle
Weltmeisterin in der Abfahrt den zweiten
Platz auf der Strecke auf der felix
Neureuther zwei Weltcupsiege gefeiert
und seine Karriere beendet hat
Glücksmomente für Anna Maria Rieder in
Kitzbühel der von Lähmungen Betroffenen
parachi alpin-fahrerin gelingt im
stehenden Slalom eine fantastische Fahrt
eine Minute und
52,88 Sekunden nur eine Athletin ist
schneller die Schwedin ever Asien sie
ist die aktuelle Weltmeisterin und
Paralympics Siegerin auch heute ist ASIO
nicht zu bezwingen sie triumphiert vor
wieder und der Französin Aurelie Richard
die zweite deutsche Teilnehmerin Andrea
Rothfuß wird vierte in Kitzbühel der
Sehbehinderte Alexander rauen gestern
noch auf dem Podest wird heute im Slalom
mit seinem Guide Benedikt staubitzer
ebenfalls Vierter
toll der Präsident des französischen
Fußballverbands Noel 3 gibt nach
Vorwürfen des Mobbings und sexueller
Belästigung sein Amt auf die Pariser
Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt der
81-Jährige drei weist alle
Anschuldigungen zurück
Weltmeister Lionel Messi ist zum siebten
Mal zum Weltfußballer des Jahres gewählt
worden die Auszeichnung als beste
Fußballspielerin hat in Paris wie im
Vorjahr die Spanierin Alexia puteias
entgegengenommen der beste steht auf der
Trophäe und Lionel Messi ist der beste
Spieler des vergangenen Jahres seit gut
zwei Monaten darf sich der Kapitän der
argentinischen Nationalmannschaft auch
Weltmeister nennen diese fünfte
WM-Teilnahme gleichzeitig der Höhepunkt
seiner Karriere
das war der einzige Titel der mir noch
fehlte und es ist im Fußball der
wichtigste
die beste Spielerin kommt aus Spanien
und heißt Alexia sie ist der Star des FC
Barcelona die 29-Jährige siegte erneut
obwohl sie bei der EM im Sommer wegen
eines Kreuzbandrisses zuschauen musste
doch bis puteas solch einer
Aufmerksamkeit zu Teil wird wie sie
Lionel Messi seit vielen Jahren erlebt
kann es noch eine Weile dauern
weltfußballsprache ist Spanisch
von Katja Hornbach
können Sie um 21:45 Uhr mit mariiert das
landger Sehen schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend Mallorca meldete heute
Unwetter zum Beispiel am Leuchtturm Cap
de Pera gab es Orkanböen mit 122 km pro
Stunde und innerhalb von 24 Stunden sind
zum Teil mehr als 150 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter gefallen von all dem
bekommen wir nördlich der Alpen nichts
mit und das liegt an dem Hoch hier über
Schottland das bringt uns auch heute
Nacht häufig klarem Himmel hin und
wieder bildet sich etwas Nebel Dunst
oder Hochnebel und vor allen Dinger
auch mal zäher sein der Wind kommt aus
nordöstlichen Richtung und die
Temperaturen sinken auf null Grad an den
Küsten von Nord und Ostsee und bis minus
10 Grad am alpenrad Höchsttemperatur
morgen liegen bei zwei Grad hier in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen und 9 Grad an
der Donau oder auch am Main und morgen
müssen sich diese Zellen Hochnebel
Felder im Alpenvorland erstmal auflösen
das wird nicht immer klappen auch in
Norddeutschland sind die Wolken etwas
dichter für viele von uns gibt's aber
wieder sehr viel Sonnenschein bei Osten
Nordostwind und an diesem Wetter wird
sich auch am Donnerstag wenig ändern am
Freitag aber dreht der Wind auf Nordwest
und am Samstag kommen dann von Norden
Regen Wolken an und am Sonntag
wahrscheinlich sogar auch Schneewolken
guten Abend